bending backwards
and then backwards again
chasing
tails round and round until
the body is over
teed out the world
Stop Believing
The Lies We Tell ourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
together
[Music]
magazines
[Applause]
[Music]
we tell ourselves
foreign
[Music]
thank you
cause all we want is to give our hearts
to someone else love that is Everlasting
the kind of love Hollywood sounds
[Music]
don't spend your life pretending you're
happy and already passed
foreign
directed a flow video at least that was
my theory in putting this one together
and granted it's a very very superficial
read on the aesthetic of Wes Anderson
but I still thought it was really fun to
make and I hope you enjoyed watching it
real quickly I just want to say a huge
thank you to ultra POI for sponsoring
this video and giving me an opportunity
to go out into DC and have fun
experiments creating flow videos if
you'd like to grab a set of those orb
POI Pro LED contact boy that I was using
in this video you can do that by heading
on over to ultrapoi.com and using the
promo code drexfactor with a zero
instead of an O at checkout that gets
you a discount on your order and it
helps out the channel so everybody wins
thanks once again to ultra POI for
sponsoring this video
and speaking of thank yous I owe thank
yous to the Friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
Ultra POI for helping you make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business friend of the channel That
is Becca becklenen thank you so very
much for supporting my channel my work
and my mission and finally this video
would not be possible were not for the
kind support of all of these awesome
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people who sit down in the description
helped make this video and all the
videos on my channel possible thank you
so very much for your wonderful support
and if you out there watching would like
to sign up to support the work that I do
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you
and if you'd like to check out other
flow videos that I've done I'm going to
go ahead and include a link to a
playlist of those videos down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you're watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you might
like this top video here because it
other people who watch my channel dug it
so maybe check that out as well thanks
so much for watching make sure to like
And subscribe and I will see you with
another video real soon
peace